in washington president biden is in
isolation again after another positive
cova test over the weekend the president
had appeared to be over his cobit
infection after testing negative last
week his doctor calls it a quote rebound
case which can happen in patients like
mr biden who have been treated with the
anti-viral drug paxlovid chief
washington correspondent major garrett
is at the white house of course we've
been monitoring updates major any idea
on how the president is feeling this
morning well good morning drake good
morning everyone president says he's
feeling fine his physician says he's
experiencing no symptoms but as everyone
knows at the stage of covet every
positive test is disruptive and the
president's schedule has been disrupted
and all this of course has also cast a
presidential spotlight on rebound cases
in a twitter video on saturday president
biden announced he tested positive again
feeling fine
the president tested positive on sunday
as well his physician called it rebound
positivity the rebound came after
negative tests thursday and friday in a
small number of cases patients can
rebound after taking the antiviral
pecslevet as the president did for the
prescribed five days paxlavid reduces
the risk of covet hospitalization it
does not eliminate the virus in the
clinical trials of tax livid less than
10 percent of people experience a
rebound of symptoms or test positivity
after completing their course of pax
levitt while testing positive after
taking pax levitt is rare biden's chief
medical advisor dr anthony fauci did so
last month tax lavid may not cure you
you may still have a rebound of symptoms
or test positivity but it worked if you
did not end up in the hospital president
biden is not receiving additional
treatment for covate and has gone back
to working in isolation as cases linked
to the ba-5 omicron variant of kovid
continued to rise nationwide dr celine
gallander recommended paxlavid to reduce
risk far too few people in this country
are accessing pax lavid than are
eligible upon completing that five-day
course you should test yourself and see
if you remain infectious to others
president has none of his original covet
symptoms runny nose cough low level
fever he had six close contacts before
that positive test on saturday all have
tested negative as has the first lady
who's tested negative throughout the
president's coveted odyssey and as is
prescribed the president will await two
negative tests before resuming full
duties eureka
major before we let you go i want to ask
you about the burn pit legislation that
was stalled in congress republicans
supported it not long ago and now
they're holding it up over what they say
are budgetary concerns where do we stand
with that
so the senate majority leader chuck
schumer said he's going to bring that
legislation back to the senate floor
today for a key procedure with the hopes
of passing it by the end of the week
this legislation would not only provide
relief to veterans exposed to toxic burn
pit fumes but also those exposed to
radiation agent orange huge piece of
legislation with as you said a large
bipartisan support until last week
republican objections over budgetary
language it's not clear if they can be
overcome there were protests on the
steps of the capitol this weekend
president biden sent over boxes of pizza
he said he would have gone over
personally but you know
kovitt jericho back to you yeah we'll
see if the pizza helps major garrett
thank you